So now that we've done the define stage,
we're moving on to the diverge stage,
right?
>> The diverge stage is the next one.
The diverge stage is a chance for
everyone to be thinking with their own
creativity and imagination,
how should this problem be solved?
>> You said solutions, so
you mean more than one, right?
>> Yeah,
we're starting to think about solutions.
Not just one.
Everybody's thinking
about many solutions.
And then the team as a whole is thinking
about whole list of solutions, and
that makes the team powerful.
Everyone has time individually
to work on some solutions, and
as they are ready with this, then they
share it with the team, and suddenly,
they're looking a whole dessert tray of
options for what the product could be.
It is so exciting.
One thing that's really exciting about
this stage is how quickly it can happen.
We do an exercise that's familiar
to some people from Gamestorming.
It is called the Crazy 8's.
>> Okay, how does that go?
>> The Crazy 8's?
You want to know?
Well, here goes.
The Crazy 8's gives everyone
a little piece of paper.
And they ask the team to sketch
eight ideas in five minutes.
Usually, the first reaction that people
have when you ask them to sketch
eight ideas in five minutes,
is they think you're crazy.
And that's why we call it the Crazy 8's.
[LAUGH]
>> Nice.
>> [LAUGH] As soon as they
answer this question,
they look at the face of the leader,
and when they see that the leader is
actually serious, then they return to
the writing and they start sketching.
In five minutes, people are able to do
five, six, seven, sometimes eight ideas.
That allows them to warm up their mind,
their creative muscles
are starting to flex.
It's kind of like a warmup for
a workout.
After that, we give the team
another piece of paper and
another five minutes and
we say from the ideas that you already
have can you give me one big sketch?
Label it clearly and
explain what are the pieces of
this layout that you're creating.
Some people might be intimidated
by the sketching process.
This is when we remind them that we're
asking them to sketch simple things.
A grid that's based of rectangles,
syntax labels,
some placeholders for
a pictures and icons should be.
With that reminder, most people
are ready to re-imagine themselves
as the creative child
that they once were.